we're in a heatwave here so uh i'm in
the woods
hello everyone this is the map of
superconductivity where as ever
i've broken down all the important parts
of the subject into a big picture
to get you up to speed quickly and as
clearly as possible
superconductors are materials which when
you cool them down to a low temperature
they lose their electrical resistance
they also have some interesting magnetic
properties
which allow them to almost magically
float
but it's not magic it's just plain old
quantum mechanics
we'll look at the different kinds of
superconductors their properties
the theory behind them the applications
in the real world
and the future avenues of research and
technology
and as we go see if you can keep count
of all the nobel prizes
first i need to tell you about magnetic
induction if you have a conducting
material which is
a material that's got electrons that can
move around freely
like a piece of metal at room
temperature and you move a permanent
magnet near to it
these electrons feel this changing
magnetic field they feel a force from it
and start moving in a circle called an
eddy current
this is called magnetic induction in a
normal metal this current dies away
quickly because the material has got
electrical resistance
the moving electrons bang into the atoms
and stop moving
giving up their energy to vibrations in
the atomic lattice warming it up
slightly
but if you do the same thing to a
superconductor because they've got zero
electrical resistance
the eddy current will never stop flowing
and will carry on circulating forever
like age of the universe forever
according to the theory
and experimentally we've seen currents
losing no energy over 25 years
zero electrical resistance also means
you can pass a direct current through a
superconductor without it losing any
energy at all
that's cool but they have another
important property to do with magnetic
fields called the meissner effect
superconductors expel any magnetic field
inside them
you know how i said that magnetic fields
induce electrical currents in conductors
well the opposite's also true any
electrical current
creates a magnetic field if a
superconductor is in a magnetic field it
gets a load of eddy currents which
create their own magnetic fields that
exactly cancel out and expel the
original magnetic field this is a
quantum effect and doesn't happen in
normal conductors
so those are the two main features of
superconductors zero electrical
resistance and the meissner effect
and when they were discovered in the
early 1900s physicists were like whoa
and then since then they've investigated
more and made a load of useful
technology out of them which we'll look
at in a bit
but first we need to look at exactly
what conditions are needed for a
superconductor to superconduct
there are three conditions you need for
a superconductor low temperatures
small enough magnetic fields and small
enough electrical
currents although these two are kind of
the same thing
the specific temperature and magnetic
field that break superconductivity
depends on the material the first
superconductors that were studied were
pure elements like mercury
aluminium or niobium and physicists
discovered that
not all of the elements superconduct
here are the ones that do
for each material as you cool them down
they undergo
a sharp transition temperature where
they suddenly start superconducting at a
sharp phase transition
and when they're in the superconducting
state if you then apply
a larger and larger magnetic field or a
larger and larger electrical current
they've got a critical field and a
critical current where they suddenly
stop
superconducting and go back through the
phase transition to a normal conductor
even if they're below the transition
temperature
now even if this is all new to you you
already know about phase transitions
because
this is what happens to water when it
freezes
when it boils these are phase
transitions too but
these are phase transitions in the
material properties
whereas the superconducting phase
transitions are transitions in the
electronic
properties but it all comes down to what
is the configuration of stuff which
minimizes
the overall energy known as the gibbs
free energy
if a material will be in a lower energy
by freezing into a solid or turning into
a superconductor
that's what it'll do anyway as any fan
of physics knows when we have
phase transitions we're going to have
say with me phase diagrams
these are very handy graphs because they
show us what state your thing
will be in when you change some global
parameters
this is a phase diagram for the state of
water when you change temperature and
pressure
which you might have seen before and
here is the analogous
example of the superconducting state and
normal conducting state
for different temperatures and magnetic
fields of a superconductor
this also changes with pressure as well
but i'm not plotting that here because
i'd need a 3d plot and superconductivity
at pressure
is a bit of a research niche the vast
majority of superconductors are used at
normal pressure
each superconductor has got its own
unique phase diagram
and filling them in kept a bunch of
experimental physicists happily busy for
years as they filled in all the points
and they didn't just stick to the
elements they started looking at
compound materials of which there are an
infinite amount and the search for new
superconductors has been going on ever
since in attempt
to find materials with higher and higher
transition temperatures
with the goal of one day finding a room
temperature superconductor
and then making tons of cash here's a
plot of the discovery of higher and
higher temperature superconductors
and along the way they've made some
startling discoveries
first of all in 1935 they discovered
type 2 superconductors which behave
differently to the superconductors i've
described so far
which were then called type 1
superconductors
type 2 superconductors behave
differently to type 1 superconductors
when they're in a magnetic field
here's a phase diagram of a type 2
superconductor
down here it still behaves like a type 1
superconductor
but then they have an intermediate state
where they do let the magnetic field
penetrate them
but only in specific points in a
formation called a magnetic
field vortex or vortices for short
here the bulk of the material is still
superconducting
but at these thread-like vortices the
material is a normal conductor
the magnetic field goes all the way
through in a certain small amount called
a magnetic flux quanta
and each one is surrounded by a swirling
supercurrent which is the name for the
electrical current in a superconductor
i just threw a load of terminology at
you there so if you're confused just
think of them as a load of
sausages and you'll be pleased to hear
that these are the only two kinds of
superconductors we've found so far
there is a kind of type 1.5
superconductor but
i can't be bothered to talk about it
here so wikipedia
the next big bombshell to hit the
exciting world of superconductivity
research was in 1986 when researchers
made a superconductor made of ceramic
which was an insulator before being
cooled down
this then led to the discovery of a
bunch of high-temperature
superconductors
although high temperature is a little
bit of a misnomer because they still
have to be cooled way below zero with
cryogenic liquids
but now you can make a thing
superconduct with just liquid nitrogen
at 77 kelvin which is way cheaper than
liquid helium
which is what they had to use before
these new superconductors are known as
the cuprates because they contain layers
of copper oxide
with a load of other stuff in there as
well and there's also many other types
of superconductor
ion-based superconductors called the
pinictides pure carbon-based
superconductors called fullerenes
and also known as organic
superconductors and there's others as
well but you get the picture
people have also squeezed materials
between diamond presses and discovered
that many materials start
superconducting when they're at very
high pressure
and recently in 2020 a room temperature
superconductor was discovered called
carbonaceous
sulfur hydride which superconducts at 15
celsius but only under a huge amount of
pressure squeezed in a diamond press so
it's not actually practically useful
but still a landmark discovery now onto
the theory of superconductivity
it was not an easy job to figure out the
underlying theory of what's actually
going on in superconducting materials at
the scale of the electrons
what's the underlying process that
allows for zero resistance
the first theory ginsberg landau theory
predicted properties of superconductors
like
which would be type 1 and type 2 but
this was superseded by a microscopic
theory called bcs theory
named after the initials of the creators
they figured out that as electrons move
through the lattice of atoms they
attract the atoms around them slightly
creating a local positive charge
which creates an attractive force
between electrons
so electrons can interact with each
other through vibrations in the lattice
called phonons
and this allows them to pair up in a
composite entity
known as a cooper pair now if you've
watched my map of particle physics
you'll know that electrons
spin half particles and obey the
parallel exclusion principle
so can't exist in the same quantum
states
but the cooper pairs behave like bosons
because when you add their spins
together you get spin zero or spin one
bosons can exist in the same quantum
state and so
all the cooper pairs form a thing called
a condensate
which has special properties including
not being able to easily
absorb kicks of energy and so they flow
without resistance
this is known as an energy gap
that's just a very quick explanation
because a full description would take a
long time
but now you've got the basics what is
interesting is this theory doesn't
explain
high temperature superconductivity
because the attractive force
from the phonons don't exist there so
they need some other attractive force
between electrons and we don't know
where that would come from in high
temperature superconductors
for this reason any superconductor that
doesn't follow bcs theory is called an
unconventional superconductor and the
ones that do are called conventional
superconductors
despite a lot of work going into this
high temperature superconductivity
is still one of the biggest unsolved
mysteries in theoretical condensed
matter physics
and you'll probably win a nobel prize
when you figure it out
there are a load of technologies which
use superconductors
the most widespread use of
superconductors is to create large
magnetic
fields as you can circulate a lot of
current in a loop without burning any
energy
this is what the big tube is in mri
machines it's basically coils and coils
of superconducting material that's
cooled down with liquid helium
superconducting magnets are also
extensively used in particle
accelerators to bend and focus the beams
of particles
they've been used in some tokamak
reactors to control plasma
in the nuclear fusion process and also
in other areas where you want to control
charged particles like mass
spectrometers
there are also many kinds of quantum
devices which use superconductors
the most useful are josephson junctions
which are small gaps between
superconductors
where the cooper pairs can still flow
across the gap through quantum tunneling
and so you get a continuous flow of
current even with no voltage
applied you can use this to set up
superpositions of current
and therefore superpositions of magnetic
field where the current and magnetic
field
are in the superposition state of
flowing in both directions at the same
time
these josephson junctions can be
combined in a specific formation called
a superconducting quantum interference
device or squid
for short which is a phenomenally
sensitive magnetic
field detector the best humanity has
discovered
these are the detectors that can see
inside your body in mri and fmri
machines
they're also what set the voltage
standard in fundamental physics
they're used as efficient radio
frequency antennas in research and in
mobile phone masts
and you can use the superposition of
states created by the josephson
junctions to make a tunable qubit
which are the building blocks of
superconducting quantum computers
this stuff is my professional background
back when i had a proper job
and i think quantum technology is
absolutely fascinating especially the
possible future technologies
so what does the future hold for
superconductors for a long time people
have talked about building transmission
lines
to transport electricity through
superconductors to significantly reduce
the amount of energy that's lost
but to be cost effective it needs to be
a superconductor that you don't need to
cool down very much
which can carry high currents and is
strong
we don't have this yet so these are the
challenges
but it would be cool to be able to ship
electricity around the grid a lot more
efficiently
you can also use superconductors for
levitating things like trains
but this potential has been around for a
while so i'm not sure there's a great
need for it
but you know it's a thing that exists a
promising area is to make very efficient
superconducting motors or generators for
things like wind
turbines which could potentially
decrease the cost of the electricity
they generate
so this would be really cool to make
renewable energy even cheaper
on the quantum devices side i think by
far the most exciting applications are
the range of quantum computers built
with superconducting qubits now
superconductors aren't the only way to
build quantum computers
but google ibm d-wave and others have
built very advanced superconducting
quantum computers
which could potentially be used to
understand and find
new superconducting materials by
simulating the quantum mechanics of them
something that currently can't be done
with our most powerful supercomputers
so you could potentially use
superconducting qubits to figure out how
high temperature superconductivity
actually works and then
perhaps use that to find a room
temperature superconductor
in fact on the research side figuring
out the mechanism of high temperature
superconductors and whether a room
temperature and room pressure
superconductor can exist
would be fantastic if we had a room
temperature superconductor it could
potentially revolutionize all
electronics
from the power grid to consumer
electronics as you'd be able to build
zero resistance computers with way lower
electricity consumption
but this all depends on the room
temperature superconductor also having a
high critical current
and critical field as well as having
material properties
that make it easy to work with to
fabricate
chips okay so that's the map of
superconductivity
i hope it was informative how many nobel
prizes did you count
it should have been five which is not
bad for one quantum phenomena
uh which one of you is going to get
number six
i've made this map available as a
digital image on flickr and a poster on
my dftba store
along with all my other posters and if
you like this video
please remember to smash that patriarchy
especially in physics i'd like to just
give a massive shout out to anyone who's
bought one of my posters
and also to my wonderful patreon
supporters
you are all helping me keep making
educational content which is free for
anyone to watch
and also helping me to decouple myself
from the
fickle youtube algorithm so that i can
concentrate on making
killer content that's also bloat free
so thank you so much and i'll see you on
the next video
you